Oh,
we can get started and this morning will be a slightly different style of
lecture.
You'll notice that you don't have handouts and that wasn't an oversight.
Uh,
it was actually because you won't need them this morning.
What we're going to be doing is something of an experiment,
which is that it seemed to me that it was useful when you were reading,
uh,
various historical works.
Dot.
Sometimes the author of one of them should explain,
uh,
and discuss with you how they came to be as they are.
So that was one of the reasons that I put my own book,
this one on Naples on the reading list.
And I thought this morning I tried the experiment of a different kind of lecture
where I talked to you about how it came to be the work that it is.
We're moving on now from the material on,
uh,
the power school and on plague and small pox to our next major epidemic disease,
which was the great fear disease of the 19th century,
which was Asiatic cholera,
which hit Europe.
It wasn't an endemic disease.
It hit Europe,
uh,
for the first time around 1830 and returned in a series of pandemics in various
waves.
Uh,
and normally the official historiography has it that about the last epidemic in
western Europe was in the 1890s.
Don The statistics of the WHO and the various countries of Europe support and
the literature as well support this conclusion that Asiatic cholera after the
1890s were turns again to western Europe only in tiny little outbreaks in,
uh,
the last of which was 1973.
So there really isn't supposedly a history of cholera in the 20th century in
Europe.
And it's not that I want to challenge and to talk with you about this morning
now as I began and here we can start into how the book came to be,
to exist at all.
I at the time,
well one,
there's this sort of,
as I started doing research on a very different topic,
I had an a sense perhaps been primed for an interest in cholera.
I had been primed because I had lived through and outbreak in Rome in 1973 and I
had noticed a number of things that it captured my attention because this was
Italy,
this world's industrial power at the time.
And I remember some strange phenomena being in Rome.
The epidemic had started and found its epicenter in the city of Naples and cars
had at that time a license plates that bore the province of origin,
uh,
of the vehicle and cars and Rome that had Naples license plates were being
stoned by the citizens of Rome.
It was also true that in the fish and vegetable markets near the apartment where
I was living,
that uh,
this stalls of the fish and vegetable sellers were attacked and overturned,
uh,
by crowds.
So there,
this seemed something that captured my imagination very clearly.
And then the minister of health went on television and said that you really
didn't need to worry because all you had to do was to squeeze because the
Vibrio,
the bacterium that causes Asiatic cholera is highly susceptible to acid.
So all you have to do is squeeze a little lemon juice on your raw muscles and
then you'll be,
can quite happily eat them.
Uh,
which I wouldn't advise any of you.
in any case,
uh,
it was also true that the prime minister and Minister of health visited Naples
and the infectious diseases hospital there,
and there's an Italian magazine in which pictures of them appeared a,
and you could see them almost running down the wards as they were visiting the
patients and behind them they had their hands.
Uh,
you can imagine trodding,
uh,
with this gesture,
which is a,
a gesture toward off the evil eye in Italian culture.
So this seemed rather strange in the world's seventh,
uh,
industrial power.
So in a sense,
I had done this subliminal message that came from an earlier experience,
but there I was,
a decade or so later and my project was,
I thought that I was interested in political philosophy and social history and I
was working on the disappearance of the European peasantry under the press of
economic circumstances and,
uh,
major transformations in the countryside and the coming of the commercial
revolution in agriculture,
urbanization,
and the industrial revolution.
But I began to have my imagination captured by a numbers of references that I
began to find around the early 20th century to call Laura and Italy around 1910.
And that seemed a little surprising to me.
And it really began,
I began to read more about it and it seemed to illustrate the how people's lives
were lived and their standard of living much better than,
uh,
the project thought I heard originally began with.
And so I let this medical project have a life of its own.
And this is what eventually became my book as I was working on,
uh,
more on cholera.
However,
something else came to the forefront of my attention.
And that was a conflict between what I read about cholera in the literature and
what I was beginning to find in my own research.
The literature said that there wasn't a major epidemic,
uh,
in the 20th century in Europe,
the last major one being in the 1890s.
But I was beginning to find odd references to some very strange events,
particularly in the summer of 1911 and I began to think that perhaps a very
interesting policy of concealment was taking place that is an epidemic that was
concealed by the authorities.
And Naples once again,
uh,
was a very interesting place.
Now Naples is,
uh,
if you're interested in Colorado and the west Naples is a very interesting place
because it was the city,
it was the largest city in Europe in the 19th century and it was scourged the
most often by this affliction.
And I'm going to be arguing that it was scourged also.
Um,
and times that aren't recorded in the standard,
a historiography of this subject and in particular in 1911,
it also is an extraordinary place because it has something happen that you won't
find elsewhere.
And that is,
this is a city that was actually after the dreadful epidemic of 1884 was rebuilt
in order to make the city collar reproof so that it wouldn't return.
So we see an extraordinary,
uh,
we talk about the impact of infectious diseases.
And here we see a case study of a place where the city itself is reconstructed
specifically as a result of an epidemic catastrophe in order not to make another
one possible.
And so we can directly see in bricks and mortar and in the sewers underground
and the buildings above and in the layout of the city,
you can see the impact of cholera end of the idea of miasma because the mayas
Madec interpretation was the one under which that guided the reconstruction of
the city,
which happened after in the way of the 1884 catastrophe.
But in 1911,
there was no public record of a major epidemic.
So I had a whiff of the fact that there was,
but I couldn't prove it.
So how do you go about demonstrating,
uh,
an epidemic that doesn't have a literature?
So I thought that the first thing that would be useful to do would be to visit
Naples.
And in particular to visit the Naples cemetery,
the cemetery is a very large one.
You can visit it yourselves.
Uh,
and it's a very monumental ground cemetery.
And I went in the middle of the week with the idea that I would go to the
registry or uh,
and perhaps their find records of burials and that I would also be able to see,
uh,
in stone the victims of a major epidemic.
In other words,
the first idea I had was not,
you can't,
in order to prove that there was an epidemic,
you would have to have a sudden bulge and mortality in the summer months of
1911.
And I thought I could demonstrate that by visiting the Naples cemetery.
And if there weren't,
there wasn't a sudden excess of death in the summer than I would know that I was
actually on the wrong trail entirely.
And I should have bound in my project.
Uh,
well as I was walking through the,
uh,
monumental cemetery,
I think it was a Wednesday or Thursday,
I suddenly had a car pull up alongside me,
uh,
and,
the mountain said,
uh,
get in,
get in.
Um,
I don't know exactly how you would have reacted.
I hesitated,
uh,
um,
particularly as it was a cemetery in which on a Wednesday and a Thursday I found
myself completely alone except for this a strange request that I got in a car
with someone I had never seen before.
Well,
it turns out to,
as we talked,
that he was the director of the cemetery and he had come to rescue me.
And so I did eventually got 10,
and he took me out of the cemetery talent scolding me and telling me that I was
obviously a stranger,
an outsider,
and a foreigner who knew nothing.
And that in fact the Naples cemetery is the most dangerous place you can be in
the city,
which has a long history of organized crime because during the week,
this was in fact where the local mafia did its drug deals and that everyone in
Naples knew this except me.
And he was possibly saving my life by removing me.
But it wasn't that I wasn't welcome.
Um,
I was welcome to come back on Saturday and Sunday because that's when all the
people of Naples,
uh,
do come to pay their respects,
to their relatives and their flower stalls and gazillions of people frequenting
the cemetery then,
and the registry office with the records was also open.
Then I also discovered that there was,
in fact by reading the newspapers surrounding the time of my visit that not very
summer there was the,
uh,
I was doing a little checking up and it turns out that the rector of the
cemetery wasn't kidding me at all.
That there was a major drug bust in this very cemetery.
And the way they had done it was that they had wired the tombstones.
Um,
and,
and this way they had a pulled off a major,
uh,
move against the Camorra,
which is the local,
uh,
if we like a subset of the organized crime families in Italy and one of the most
important crime syndicates in the world in modern times.
So that was not brought me back on a weekend.
And on the weekend I discovered that there was in fact a big mortality bulge,
that there were a lots of people who'd been buried in the summer of 1911,
well,
in excess of the year before 1910 and 1909 or the years that were succeeded.
1912 or 1913 and there was a book that have red registered the deaths and
burials and there was a huge bulge in 1911.
So I knew something had happened.
And,
uh,
something was interesting because the,
one of the features of the book that's the register of burials is not,
they provide the neighborhood from which the deceased,
uh,
was resident.
But in this case,
uh,
they,
instead of the usual record of a neighborhood,
they had,
uh,
the marking cartoon,
you'll hospital was the last place that the deceased had been.
And the [inaudible] hospital then as now was the Infectious Diseases Hospital of
the city.
So I suddenly knew that there was this great excess of mortality in the summer
of 1911 and that the mortality was from infectious diseases because the people
had been buried in vast numbers from the cartoon Tunio hospital as their last
port of call.
So then the next thought,
um,
and I think a lot of historical work is a bit like detective work and I found
myself playing a sort of detective role.
So my next place to visit was the Katrina Hospital,
uh,
of infectious diseases.
And,
uh,
I've just made two findings there that we're confirming me in my vision of what
might have happened.
Uh,
thought they were,
there was a,
in the library of the hospital,
the hospital itself had preserved its own records,
our patient records.
And after some persistence,
I was allowed to look at patient records in the hospital and found something
interesting and mysterious.
And that was that there were records of the,
uh,
patient records through 1908,
nine 10 and the first half,
first half of 1911 and then suddenly there were no records at all.
Uh,
there was a mysterious disappearance of the records of the patients of the
hospital.
Uh,
then I went to the library of the Infectious Diseases Hospital where there was a
second interesting thing,
which was not,
the hospital had its own.
Um,
we're search journal that published recording the research findings of its own
physicians,
its own house physicians and interns and residents.
The result of that was to discover that for surprise surprise in the summer of
1911 the physicians of the cartoon,
your hospital,
we're doing lots and lots of research on therapeutics for Asiatic Cholera.
Uh,
they were experimenting with giving patients ice and lots of other therapeutic
procedures that we'll talk about in a couple of minutes.
So,
uh,
value now knew that the physicians of the Infectious Diseases Hospital were
enormously preoccupied with Asiatic cholera.
Uh,
then the next place was to go to the local archives where I was told that my
idea was impossible.
There was no such thing that there are also,
uh,
the local records had been moved in,
during the Second World War Two,
uh,
out of the city for keeping to the sanctuary of Monte Cassino and uh,
and Abby outside of the city.
But I think the number of you have heard of Monte Cassino,
it became a major battle site in the war.
And so,
uh,
the Abbey itself and all of the archives went up in flames.
And so all the records of the city for the period I was interested in were
destroyed.
And I was told that a project of the kind that I was imagining was,
uh,
inconceivable and also couldn't be carried out.
So what do you do next if you think there's a major epidemic and,
uh,
you want to demonstrate its existence.
So the next thing that happened,
uh,
was not,
I had the idea that this was a time in 1911.
That was the height of mass emigration of Italians.
That is,
I've said that I had been studying the disappearance of the European peasantry
and that its transformation into workers or uh,
urban dwellers and want a part of that was the extraordinary story of Italian,
a transoceanic migration in large part to this country,
but also to Australia and other places.
So I thought if there really was an mass movement and Naples is,
was then,
uh,
a port,
it was one of Europe's along with harp,
Hem Borg,
Hum Board,
uh,
major,
port cities and what Naples specialized in if Homburg specialize and goods and
surfaces.
Naples specialize in the export if people,
and in particular at Italian emigrants,
uh,
to,
New York City,
there was enormous transoceanic migration.
So I thought,
well,
if this is true and these,
uh,
thousands,
hundreds of thousands of emigrants are moving through the city of Naples and
there is a major cholera epidemic and they're arriving at Ellis island,
we'll surely some of them will have,
uh,
been afflicted with the disease and there would be records there of that at
Ellis island.
Well as it turns out,
this was true,
uh,
there were records,
cholera did break out on a series of demographic bearing ships in the summer of
1911 and people were quarantined for the disease Italians that is,
who had last been in Naples where quarantine for the disease on Ellis Island.
And indeed there had been a number of people who were released from quarantine
and fell ill on the main land.
And so there are perhaps a dozen,
um,
cases of people who felt sick in New York state and not on Ellis Island itself.
So we know that there was,
then there were Italian immigrants coming to the United States who were
afflicted with the disease.
So this led me to think,
well,
I do have a project and now the point is to prove it further,
what can I find out about it's reasons?
What are the politics of concealment and so on.
And I was lucky then because I was interested in a physician called Leonard
Rodgers,
who was one of the world's experts in tropical medicine at the early years of
the 20th century.
And it was he who in 1908,
made a major discovery in terms of the therapeutics of Asiatic Cholera,
uh,
down to 19,
oh nine.
There was nothing that physicians could do that was effective and helpful for
their patients.
And so the case fatality rate was something like 50% for Asiatic cholera in 1908
in 1909,
uh,
Leonard Rogers,
who was a British physician working in India had found,
uh,
that he could reduce the mortality from 50 to 15%.
Um,
the first major advance in therapeutics.
And he did it one by a simple,
uh,
building on a,
something that had been observed from the 1830s.
And that is to say the cholera kills by dehydration,
the bodily fluids flow out of the rectum and the mouth through vomiting at an
extraordinary rate so that human beings lose up to three quarters of the fluid
portion of their blood serum.
And so from the 1830s onward,
one of the therapeutic ideas was why not simply replace the fluids?
So,
uh,
there were major attempts early on to get people to drink lots of liquid.
That doesn't work because you're simply vomited up.
It has no effect except to make the patient weaker.
So,
uh,
having discovered that there were attempts by physicians to replace the fluids,
intravenously,
uh,
the problem early on was not,
there was not a knowledge.
There are several problems.
How much liquid do you actually administer?
And many patients died of heart failure from an excess of fluid.
Uh,
it was also a time before the discovery of the germ theory of disease.
And so,
although,
uh,
they were given drips that had clean water,
it wasn't sterile and patients died of septicemia.
Uh,
it was also true that,
uh,
another discovery,
which was not the patients,
what made people persist with rehydration is not this administration of liquid
because the patients to feel much better briefly for a few hours,
they seem to recover.
They would sit up in their beds and feel infinitely better.
So something clearly positive was going on,
but what it was wasn't understood.
And what happened was that,
uh,
if the administration of fluid was trying to replace fluid than had the same
salinity as the blood of the bar,
uh,
that,
that in the body,
uh,
unfortunately it is not retained by tissues,
and it merely pours out of the body again.
And so the patient who had momentarily for a few hours felt better relapses.
And even the continuing of this therapeutic attempt had no positive effect.
Well,
Leonard Rogers discovered in 1909 a number of things.
He measured the amount of fluid loss.
Um,
he,
uh,
used a distilled water and he made it a hypertonic that is a much more sane lean
than the blood fluid.
And the result of that was that it was retained through mechanisms that aren't
very well understood.
The fluid was retained.
And so Leonard,
Ron Jurors was able to save the lives of the vast majority of the patients.
She treated for Asiatic collar in India.
And he wanted to demo.
The problem was this was a time,
uh,
in medical history when there were racial ideas of disease and it was thought
the fact that he had discovered this with Indian bodies,
uh,
would have nothing to do with European bodies.
And so partly for humanitarian reasons and partly for scientific reasons,
he was looking for,
uh,
an outbreak of cholera in the West in which he could apply his therapeutics and
demonstrate their ability to save life,
any human life.
And in 1911 because he was watching very closely,
he realized that there was an epidemic afoot in Italy and he sought permission
to go to Naples to demonstrate the efficacy of his new procedures.
So soon I had Leonard,
I was in contact with Leonard Roger's family,
and I had access to his papers and his discussion of what happened to him in the
summer of 1911 which ones,
not to admit that there Wa that to admit him to the hospital,
Naples to train physicians and saving lives the best available practice.
The only therapy that had any effect would be to admit the presence of an
epidemic.
And so he wasn't allowed to come to mainland Italy.
Instead,
he was allowed a two week visit to Sicily where the disease spread as well.
And the Italian physicians,
they're called him the prince of medicine because they had a survival rate under
his direction and his new rehydration method of 85%,
which was extraordinary,
uh,
by international standards,
he had discovered the first collective therapy one that is in fact the basis of
present day therapy for cholera,
which is oral rehydration.
Ah,
Leonard Rogers methods have been perspect perfected,
but he was the one who found an effective rehydration system so soon.
We knew then that the state in Italy for various reasons,
was preserving a secret and denying its own citizens the most available of the
most effective,
the only effective available system of care.
So Leonard Rogers left Italy in great disappointment after only being allowed to
visit the collar awards in Sicily and was denied by the state,
the ability to visit a,
to visit Naples,
which was the epicenter of what was happening.
Then the next thing,
uh,
I was able to discover was that the records for this epidemic,
there were records,
but they existed not in the usual places that scholars would think of to study
public health.
Uh,
the first files on this that I discovered,
uh,
were in police records and they happen in an odd way,
which was that the prime minister of Italy ordered the state police in their
Italy to deal with the new offense,
which was sanitary defeatism.
And in order to preserve silence and not promote sanitary defeatism,
they began tapping,
uh,
the,
telephone lines used by physicians and censoring and opening physicians male.
And in the city of Venice in 1911,
there were actually the police records that demonstrated the following,
which was to say that the Venice Medical Society decided quite sensibly in the
summer of 1911 that it would save lives and enable people to protect themselves
by publishing pamphlets and distributing them about Asiatic Cholera and how you
can protect yourself against it.
And they printed thousands of these and wall posters as well to put up on the
walls.
If Venice instead the medical society was visited by the police who confiscated
and burned all of the pamphlets and all of the wall posters and told the
physicians of Venice the city that to propagate health and sanitary defeatism
would be fatal to their careers.
So they are there.
This was all preserved in the records,
uh,
of the police regarding the summer of 1911 in Venice.
The next place that I visited done,
um,
was the national archives here and discovered that Italy had signed in 1903 on
this is means that all of the things that I'm telling you about mark to
violation also of international law because in 1903,
there was a Paris sanitary convention which made the full disclosure of an
infectious diseases mandatory for Italy.
And the United States were both signatories along with a series of other
countries and the physician who represented the United States in 1903,
a major cholera expert named Henry gettings had,
was now stationed as nape at Naples as the u with the u s embassy are directing
the medical service there.
Why Naples?
Because Naples was the center of mass emigration from Italy to the United
States,
and there were health inspections that took place in the city before departure.
And Henry gettings was therefore in charge of protecting the health of the
United States by heading off infectious diseases before people leave and boarded
the ship.
Well,
in 1911,
there's an extensive correspondence and a very happy,
unhappy correspondence by Henry gatting's and people in the United States,
including his superiors and his family about his experiences in the city where
he tried to report to the United States government that there was a major
epidemic of Asiatic cholera.
He found that his life was threatened in the city of Naples,
uh,
and his superiors in the United States.
We're not at all enthusiastic about receiving his message of what was taking
place.
And so the United States government,
you've met Walter Wyman in your study of the bubonic plague,
uh,
and the Barbaree plague in San Francisco where we meet him here again,
actually colluding with the Italian government in the suppression of knowledge
about this important major infectious disease against international law that the
United States had actually signed.
Um,
then there were an addition to that.
I then went back to,
uh,
the police files and discovered that there were also health statistics that were
coming in to Rome,
a reporting events in the Italian provinces and they included statistics for
Asiatic at cholera,
but the prefects who are the highest authority for law and order in each Italian
province today.
As then we're actually sending back to health officers and the various
provinces,
the statistics they were receiving saying that these aren't good statistics,
we don't want them send us something better.
And so you actually see the process by which the state manufactured the health
statistics that were subsequently published and are the basis for the
historiography.
And you can read those statistics in World Health Organization reports and
Italian government reports and in US government reports of the summer of 1911.
Now,
why is this true and why was this so sensitive?
Uh,
this meant that I needed to go back in time.
And so my first idea was to write the second half of the book about concealment
and I'm introducing that I think that's important in our course because we're
talking about various strategies of public health and so far we've looked at
plague regulations and we've looked at vaccine,
but there's,
as you will remember,
probably from the SARS outbreak that China practice to policy of concealment at
the outset.
What I'm trying to say is that concealment is also a style of public health
policy.
And uh,
I think our newspapers rather miss lettuce and leading us to believe that this
was some plea unique to China.
Something very unusual.
I would argue as well that this is probably something that's been resorted to a
number of times.
And this epidemic of 1911 is a good example and a good case study in which one
can find the actual documents of the concealment and the reasons that it took
place.
Well,
why this pressure?
Why does the Prime Minister of Italy collude and why the United States,
uh,
the public,
surgeon general of the United States also colluded with that.
Indeed.
Uh,
I would tell you another little anecdote which was a,
that Walter Weinman had a friend who was the,
uh,
friends a couple he knew who were the parents of um,
young Johnny who just finished his Ba degree in 1911,
I'm sorry,
not here in new haven,
but rather that other unmentionable place in Cambridge,
mass.
And having finished his degree in 1911 as a newly minted bachelor of arts,
it was planning a grand tour,
which was going to take in Italy.
And,
uh,
he,
Italy had,
this was the 50th anniversary of Italian unification and there was a major fair
with our grand us pavilion and Johnny was planning to visit until that is a,
he got a letter from his friend,
the US surgeon general who wrote to Johnny's parents that this trip simply
wasn't on in the summer of 1911 because due to infectious diseases,
it wasn't safe,
uh,
to visit Italy.
Um,
uh,
the Mucus pavilion also the,
people,
the organizers wrote back to Washington saying that they were scandalized and
horrified because,
uh,
American citizens,
we're not being warned that in fact there was cholera are rampant in Italy and
their health was at risk and there was no knowledge of this and no cover of it,
of coverage of it and the press.
Well,
why would this be happening?
the first thing,
uh,
that is that by this time there was an enormous stigma associated with Asiatic
cholera,
Asiatic cholera by in western Europe and in North America was supposedly
vanquished by the bulwarks of sanitation and public health.
Cholera is a spread by the ingestion and only one way,
which is the ingestion of food and water contaminated with fecal matter.
And so it really is an indictment of sanitary standards.
And therefore one of the features was in a matter of national pride for
Italians,
not to admit that there was in fact there were these deficiencies in sanitary
standards in,
uh,
a nation that was supposedly advanced and silk.
And as they would have said,
civilized.
And so part of it then is avoiding stigma.
This was an important part of what happened.
But in addition,
there was a,
uh,
a patriotism involved because this was the 50th anniversary of Italian
unification and the whole world was descending on Italy or so,
it seemed an Italian soaked and to destroy the festivities by putting them off,
by warning the world that cholera was rampant in Italy at this time would have
had enormous economic repercussions for tourism,
a major industry.
It also would have had major repercussions,
uh,
in terms of pride in counseling.
The whole of the celebrations.
A second feature.
Another feature has to do as the fact that I've just said that the Italian
economy and Italian standards of living were dependent in part on the export of
people at this time.
These were emigrants who came to these shores and to South America and then sent
back very large scale remittances that were very important to the Italian
economy.
And what would have happened if the 1903 sanitary convention had terms had been
enforced and Italy as it should have and was legally committed to doing,
had announced the presence of Asiatic cholera that would have stopped emigration
to these shores and to South America.
And that was something that Italians did not want to risk.
And this also could have had a repercussions in terms of civil disorder.
So there was a fear that then to cholera as we'll see is much associated with
social tension and disorder.
And that was another fear that was very much in the minds of Italians.
But then there's something very specific and that is that,
as I said in the beginning of our talk this morning,
that Naples had been made,
supposedly cholera proof after the summer of 1884 when a catastrophic epidemic
had ravaged the city and massive commitment of funds,
Italian,
but also a Neapolitan and from abroad had been devoted to this rebuilding of the
city.
The problem is I've already said that Naples was the center of the Camorra of
major criminal syndicate and was a place where funds often disappeared in
mysterious channels.
And one of the features of the rebuilding project was not the money,
uh,
largely went into undisclosed and corrupt channels.
And so here we have a city which is supposedly been built like the titanic,
just hitting another iceberg and discovering that in fact the funds that were to
have made it safe have been misspent.
And there was an opposition to this municipal government in Naples,
which was using health as one of the complaints of the opposition parties.
The opposition parties in Naples at the time were Republicans,
socialists,
anarchists.
And so part of the danger then from the standpoint of the government of the day
was not to admit this would lead to a major local scandal and wood,
if you like,
a legitimate the complaints and accusations of a radical left wing opposition.
And so a consideration of political stability,
uh,
was also part of the calculation.
And this in fact was a motivating factor for the US surgeon general and the u s
government.
That here was a friendly government.
Dot was being lampooned and lambasted by a radical,
very left wing opposition and it was better to cooperate them with the
government,
the legitimate government in the face of this opposition.
Well,
this concealment then went forward and it was orchestrated at the various
highest levels.
The press was censored.
Health defeatism actually then became something that the police regarded as an
infringement and repressed.
We've seen the way in which physicians and public health authorities were
censored and were threatened.
Um,
in addition,
it was not discussed in parliament.
Uh,
you and even it wasn't discussed in the Naples municipal council.
And if you read the reports and I read the discussions of what was being
discussed and Naples in the summer of 1911,
you see a discussion of the need for hiring lots and lots of nurses.
Um,
uh,
the need for many more doctors and you see that they're importing massive
quantities of snow from the APP and nines and the Alps are into the city and
it's taken to the catune your hospital and their new few correlate that with
what the physicians were doing.
They were giving ice to cholera patients on the ward to deal with the tremendous
thirst that they had and to replace,
they hoped some of the fluid that they were losing through the course of the
disease.
So that was all this conspiracy then is not a casual one.
It's organized from the top down and is a very,
um,
major and well organized,
uh,
plot to conceal the existence of this epidemic.
In addition,
then,
what were the consequences of concealment?
I want to argue that throughout this course that public health is dependent on
accurate and timely information.
We'll see that today in a major feature of public health policies is
surveillance and monitoring and the availability of information nationally and
internationally is vital to contain and prevent pandemic afflictions.
So one of the features,
and I think 1911 is a good example of what happens if you don't provide
information.
Uh,
first thing would happen was that this disease spread through many provinces of
Italy.
It was not contained domestically.
Fortunately it did not spread to these shores and to Argentina and to other
places where large numbers of Italians went.
But I think that was a no thanks to the Italian government.
It had to do with serendipity and good luck.
What why you could say was that the Italian government with the collusion of the
u s government was placing the health of this country and the health of
Argentina in particular at risk.
It was placing at risk.
The health also have international visitors to Italy,
tourists and people who came to see the celebrations of 1911 and one of the
truly unfortunate parts of the concealment effects is that it led to thousands
of deaths of Italians because the patients on the wards of the cartoon hospital
and elsewhere in Italy were systematically denied what was then the best
available international practice,
which is the administration of rehydration therapy as developed by Leonard
Rogers and Italian doctors weren't allowed to know that this was the state of
the art and the way in which it was possible to save Italian wives reducing
mortality from 50 to 15% or something like that.
So if you look at the cartoon,
your award,
what were the physicians doing instead?
We'll instead,
because cholera patients become a tremendously cold and look as though they've
been cadaver rise.
They were immersing cholera patients in hot tubs.
Um,
they,
because for the same way as their energy was failing,
they were administering them.
Stimulants,
caffeine.
And there were various experiments with other things that were meant to because
there wasn't a therapy that was known to work.
There were lots of experimental therapies that were being tried,
strict cunning,
which you know,
better as rat poison was also administered to cholera patients in an attempt to
revive their energy and they're flagging,
um,
health.
Um,
there was also,
there were attempts at rehydration therapy,
but this took the,
uh,
the form that was now outdated after 19 away of trying to get the patients to
suck on ice or to drink or to be injected with,
um,
isotonic,
saint lean solutions that is of the same content of Saul's same salinity as the
blood,
which by 1908 through a century of experience was known to be entirely useless.
Um,
and there were,
these were the kinds of therapies that were being practiced plus simply
supportive nursing care.
And as I said,
the hospital was recruiting very large numbers of nurses,
so nursing care and various experimental and sometimes heroic interventions that
led to a very high mortality rate.
When in fact 80,
it was possible to save about 85% of patients.
Well,
I've run out of time.
And so I'll just say then that the,
uh,
this is how this particular book came to be.
And I ended up writing,
adding on that in order to understand 1911,
it was absolutely crucial to see 1884 and the steps that had been taken,
unfortunately not so successfully to make Naples collar approved by the early
20th century when sadly it wasn't.
And I think there's a story there of concealment as a public health policy that
I wanted to alert you to as yet another style of public health and one that has
very,
it's not good for your health and has very dire consequences.